this is Pierce an African crested  porcupine the largest porcupine in the  world it can weigh over sixty pounds  when alarmed it's coarse quills can be  raised into a crest making themselves  look a lot bigger than they are  it is mostly heavily armored in its  hindquarters which have short thick  quills these quills can get stuck into  its predators skin a good weapon when  dealing with hyenas leopards and even  lions  Pierce is mostly a herbivore eating  roots bulbs and crops along with the  occasional insect  unfortunately for his species crested  porcupines are seen as an agricultural  pest and is open land rapidly shrinks  they come into closer quarters with  farmers and will hunt them out of their  home this is the African crested  porcupine  [Music]